all right here we go again against mr.
grope that's pretty cool if you can
maintain such a high rating with that
crap opening funny and he he played this
against me in the live broadcast and got
a completely terrible position out of
the opening let's see where his big
novelty is probably not coming whole
night 83 Wow yeah well I mean that is so
quite clearly good for black but it's
chaotic certainly okay I can take d for
that was my idea at least I can also
take g4 but this is check so probably
not bad okay I'm taking him
just so white has sect two pawns you
will probably get one back and my
development isn't great so he definitely
has some kind of compensation it's um
shouldn't be enough but it's sewn okay
so let's develop some stuff here when
for keep it simple and Method him the
chick chan has to give up castling yeah
well for player plays the group this is
like not very important i guess you used
you're used to having some weird
positions okay so let's develop a little
bit Jim
you want to draw here mr. group he said
isn't that isn't that weird yeah he
placed his wacky opening and now he
wants a draw now I don't want to draw
yeah to a 6 I guess
Jim how to do that I cannot cancel
unfortunately
but I want to let's see maybe is going
in this one a g6 is like Bishop tea for
my but I can I can go to yourself it's
not a big deal this I obviously did not
see oh shoot how
ah
oh my goodness just one mistake and you
spoil the whole thing I really have no
move here it sits directly lost their
damn maybe c5 still playable and that
might be still playable but just about
maybe maybe not i mean does the only
thing i saw now
yeah I complete complete chaos not sure
what you should do queen of five maybe
never had a balut g5 so I might overlook
stuff him
Joe seems to be just about playable I be
sure to look to d6 that's a cool move
I have to play this hair I guess it
seems like the only move but might still
be playable okay rook is hanging on d 1
i'm happy to trade here really happy
check
I don't believe in this year check Wow
gent that a pretty dangerous check mr.
grope checkmate it was a dangerous check
whoa that was lucky after overlooking g5
yeah in the opening well that I have a
hard time to believe okay this this and
now I grabbed but he def he had play I
mean definite play with all this
development yeah the engine gives gives
me a slight edge but it is such a rocky
position Jack now look g1 now given by
the engine with white being better for
lucrative one I guess and the computer
wants to do this move simply cover f5
Wow
check so with where did I give up on the
advantage checking here that seems us
better maybe because I can know what
this one I can develop now like this
that is very tough very tough loss okay
i'm curious how worse that was out i
overlooked g5 k this this one might have
six Bishop f5 yeah I now 95 is given by
the comp and yeah I will look g5 simply
I can go see five here which is ok but
should be five is good for one as well
and here I'm yeah I should lose assess
the engine with takes takes root chips I
had the suspicion it just looks looks
bad here at the king that's what the
computer is giving with a winner and
here I'm am also lost after f4 I'm also
lost here this however is still ok and
TM when Jack Bishop d3 bhushan of six is
also winning and this is Chet it's made
poor I was a less lucky escape really
lucky escape okay i hope you enjoyed the
video it was funny with the group thanks
for watching